les médecins aussi le globale des tarifs
visite médicale plus cher à partir de
lundi crédit nouvelle augmentation des
taux d'intérêt la troisième en trois
semaines drogue agitation séquestration
ou vavin sun la réponse en direct du
président merle là messieurs bonsoir la
hache de guerre est donc à nouveau
déterrée entre les médecins et la
sécurité sociale la réunion
d'aujourd'hui destinée à élaborer une
nouvelle convention n'a permis aucun
progrès on se reverra la semaine
prochaine le 19 mars mais d'ores et déjà
le principal syndicat de médecins a
décidé d'engager les hostilités avec les
cases assurance maladie et le
gouvernement en demandant à tous ses
adhérents d'appliquer unilatéralement
dès lundi une majoration de 12 à 14% des
honoraires
nous avons fixé les prix des services
médicaux aux tarifs houle devrait être
si le gouvernement n'avait pas bloqué
les eaux naya je vous rappelle que la
zone art sont bloquées depuis le mois de
juillet 79 et les chiffres que nous
avons données sont vraiment modeste et
raisonnable puisque c'est 45 francs pour
la consultation du médecin praticien et
68 francs pour la consultation du
spécialiste
nous avons volontairement accepté et si
j'ose dire ce blocage et honoraires
parce que nous voulions pas nuire à la
négociation conventionnelle mais cette
négociation s'attarder ce qu'on nous
propose est en projet que nous ne
pouvons pas accepter
oui et ajoutons à cela que ce sont les
assurés qui feront les frais de cette
nouvelle décision puisque les
consultations continueront d'être
remboursés au tarif anciens la situation
de la sécurité sociale devient donc
passablement compliqué alors essayons
d'y voir clair
en juillet dernier le gouvernement prend
une série de mesures pour tenter de
combler le déficit de la sécurité
sociale
il dessine notamment de bloquer les
honoraires des médecins jusqu'à la
signature d'une nouvelle convention
il demande aux salariés de payer une
cotisation supplémentaire pendant 18
mois
cotisation égale à 1 % du salaire
aujourd'hui les médecins décident tout
seul d'augmenter leurs tarifs
c'est un petit peu comme si les salariés
décidé aujourd'hui de ne plus payer
leurs cotisations supplémentaires
on comprend aisément par cet exemple que
c'est un pas nouveau dans l'escaladé qui
est franchie alors pourquoi cette
escalade et bien parce que les
négociations sur cette future convention
sont actuellement dans l'impasse et
elles sont dans l'impasse sur deux
points essentiels
premier point les responsables de la
sécurité sociale veulent faire adopter
une règle extrêmement strictes les
dépenses de santé distille ne doivent
pas augmenter plus vite que les recettes
réponse des médecins nous sommes
d'accord pour que tous ensemble nous
fassions un effort pour maîtriser
l'évolution des dépenses de santé
mais nous ne sommes pas d'accord pour
entrer dans un système trop rigide
parce que disent les médecins ne sommes
pas responsable d'une épidémie de grippe
nous sommes pas responsables n'ont plus
de l'évolution des prix des produits
pharmaceutiques
sur le premier point c'est donc un non
très nette deuxième point la sécurité
sociale propose qu'il y ait en fait deux
types de médecins les médecins
totalement conventionnés et des médecins
qui serait simplement à gré dans ce
dernier cas le médecin fixerait
librement ses honoraires ces
consultations seraient remboursés mais
un tarif moindre que le tarif
conventionné réponse des médecins à
cette proposition
c'est un non catégorique aussi les
médecins disent si nous adoptons ce
système nous aurons deux types de
médecine une médecine pour les peaux ce
sera la médecine conventionnelle une
médecine pour les riches ce sera la
médecine à gré c'est un problème grave a
ajouté médecin langage tout le monde
il engage toute la société ce n'est pas
à nous médecins de décider c'est au
parlement qu'il appartient de trancher
deuxième débat de la journée débat
relancé par la condamnation hier soir à
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité de
norbert garceau l'avocat général vous le
savez avait requis la peine de mort le
verdict ainsi d'ailleurs que la paix
doit riz de l'avocat de la défense
maître badinter ont été l'occasion d'un
déchaînement des passions de part et
d'autre ces passions sont d'ailleurs le
reflet d'une opinion française très
divisée c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
soir encore nous rouvrons le dossier
avec d'abord ces statistiques qui
conclut un abandon de fête et peut-être
provisoire seulement de la peine
capitale
bernard marck est aujourd'hui 12 mars
1980 il n'y a plus de condamnés à mort
dans les prisons françaises
norbert garceau était le dernier
jusqu'au mois d'octobre 79 date à
laquelle la cour de cassation avait
annulé le verdict de mort de la cour
d'assises du tarn depuis le début du
septennat de monsieur giscard d'estaing
trois condamnés ont été guillotinés
christian ranucci en juillet 76
jérôme k rhin en juin 77 et hamida
djandoubi en septembre 77
le président de la république a gracié
quatre fois d'abord en février 76 le
jeune bruno un mineur meurtrier d'une
vieille dame ensuite en août 76 moussa
benza rats et en février 77 joseph
keller et marcelin hors neige les
meurtriers de deux jeunes britanniques
depuis trois ans
le président de la république n'a pas eu
l'occasion d'exercer ou non son droit de
grâce car la cour de cassation a annulé
cinq verdicts de mort prononcée contre
michel bodin mohamed yara oui michel
rousseau j'emportais et norbert garceau
de 1968 à 1978
trente neuf condamnations à mort ont été
prononcées par les cours d'assises
françaises
huit ont été exécutés par cette pub de
transition que nous semblons vivent en
ce moment n'est pas étranger à
l'exacerbation des passions que l'on a
encore constaté à toulouse pour robert
badinter il est temps que cela cesse et
que l'on pose enfin clairement le
problème
l'attitude d'une ici consiste à dire il
va y avoir débat parlementaire puis il
n'y a pas de débat parlementaire se fait
au moins 3 fois qu'on annonce la
commission des lois demande l'abolition
demande qu'on inscrit à l'ordre du jour
samedi à jamais ce qui fait que lui qui
se dit à la fois il y a marche vers
l'abolition et en même temps la peine de
mort subsistent
on a l'impression qu'elle est prononcée
puis que ensuite la firme et c'est une
espèce d'incertitude et quelquefois
proche de l'envoi ce qui est exaspérant
moi je crois qu'il faut ensuite
je crois qu'il est grand temps à tous il
n'ya pas d'élections législatives en vue
que le parlement prenne ses
responsabilités il est temps que le
ministre a le courage d'aller devant le
parlement et de soumettre la seule vraie
question
abolition ou pas abolition disons
suspension pendant cinq ans ou maintien
de la situation actuelle
réponse de ceux qui s'opposent toujours
à l'abolition rien ne presse le
parlement se prononcera en temps utile
nous écoutons l'un des chefs de file des
partisans de la peine de mort
jean foyer le président des commissions
de les doigts à l'assemblée nationale
le plaça del morts je ne suis pas
favorable à la bronca l'abolition de la
peine de mort je pense d'une part il
faut conserver dans l'arsenal législatif
français une peine qui n'est pas comme
on l'a dit une pinte vengeance qui n'est
pas la peine de dany du talion mais qui
est une mesure d'élimination qui est
indispensable à l'égard d'un certain
nombre de grands criminels
particulièrement dangereux et qui le
reste des années et des années encore et
je pense d'autre part que si on
abolissait la peine de mort à l'heure
actuelle on aura on n'aboutira pas à un
autre résultat que celui de relancer les
manifestations de justice privée de
légitime défense déformer le nom des
gens tout failli me paraissent beaucoup
plus grave est beaucoup plus redoutable
que le maintien de la peine de mort et
les quelques applications on en ferait
de temps en temps pas donc un argument
reste peu le fait que tout doucement le
problème c'est un petit peu transformés
et abouti pour aujourd'hui à la seule
responsabilité des jurés mais oui j'ai
bien moi je viens regarder les jurés de
toulouse déjà vous dire je me suis
trompé sur leur décision j'étais
persuadé qu'ils allaient prononcé une
peine de mort ceux qui les y aura été
les leurs droits leur plus le plus
strict et personne n'aurait eu le droit
non plus le leur reprocher les jurés
qu'est ce que c'est ce sont des
francaise devions du nombreuses
d'ailleurs et des français comme vous et
moi tiré au sort des gens de bonne foi
provenant de toutes les catégories
sociales et de toutes les régions
il retombe brusquement sur le dos une
responsabilité pouvant table le droit de
vie ou de mort ils l'assument selon
leurs convictions et leur conscience
en oubliant les pressions les voisins la
fin
il a foulé parfois les menaces cinq fois
de suite dans les villes différentes sur
des dossiers différents ils ont rejeté
cette peine de mort au moment où tout le
monde dit que tout le monde veut la
maintenir
il ya là une contradiction qui n'est pas
simplement un jeu d'esprit
d'intellectuels laxiste et cette
situation trouble où on ne sait plus
très bien où est la loi n'est vraiment
pas bonne pour la sérénité de la justice
et l'instant le radical de gauche roger
gérard schwartzenberg de proposer
l'abolition de la peine de mort dans les
neuf pays de la communauté européenne il
l'a fait devant l'assemblée de
strasbourg juste il toujours
condamnation pour recel du cinéaste
françois pin quatre mois de prison qui
couvre la durée de sa détention
préventive
en revanche il est relaxé du chef
d'infraction à la loi anti casseurs ils
n'avaient rien d'agressif estimé
aujourd'hui le tribunal qui le jugeait
pour sa participation aux événements du
23 mars dernier à paris françois pas
toujours protesté de son innocence
et puis le procès aujourd'hui de notre
confrère philippe alexandre poursuivi
par plusieurs dirigeants du rpr pour
diffamation au moment de la mort de
robert boulin pas d'information à cette
heure sur le déroulement de ce procès la
marée noire maintenant ce sont près de
600 hommes 650 me dit on même qui
luttent essentiellement à trégastel et
appelons manas pour débarrasser la côte
de granit rose de sa natte gluante
les responsables veulent faire vite car
à la fin la semaine ils veulent éviter
que la grande marée n'aggrave la
situation
ils ont bon espoir de toute façon d'en
finir au terme de quatre semaines et il
réaffirme aujourd'hui avec force que les
touristes peuvent venir dès le mois de
mai en bretagne toute annulation serait
pour une catastrophe comparable à la
mauvaise saison qui avait suivi
l'échouage de l'amoco cadiz
il reste toujours le danger que
représentent les pas coulé à 50 km des
côtes et qui aujourd'hui puis un peu
certains maires propose d'ailleurs qu'on
fasse carrément sauté l'est pas en tout
cas une certitude depuis ce matin les
presses mille tonnes de la partie
arrière sont définitivement à l'abri
ouah en régaler et patrice du tertre ont
suivi le convoi sur le tanio même
pendant la fin de la nuit et le début de
la matinée
pour les abeilles du havre remorquer un
bateau cela fait partie de la routine
cette nuit pourtant ce n'était pas un
navire comme les autres le tanio et sa
cargaison maudite a tué huit fois et le
pétrole de sa partie avant continue de
souiller les plages bretonnes
l' or noir coûte cher et d'abord en vies
humaines par une mère démentiel les
hélicoptères de la marine et les hommes
des remorqueurs ont pris tous les
risques pour sauver trente et une
personnes et empêcher une plus grande
catastrophe écologique
dix mille tonnes de pétrole remplissent
encore les soutes de la partie arrière
du navire soit une somme de 8 millions
de francs la facture sera plus lourde
pour nettoyer la côte de granit rose
pour mener à bien l'opération de
remorquage une dizaine de marins ont été
transférés cette nuit sur la partie
arrière du pétrolier depuis cinq jours
deux d'entre eux n'avaient pas quitté le
tanio pour surveiller la remorque cinq
jours passés dans une mer formée sans
électricité ni chauffage
bercés seulement par les bruits
inquiétants de la coque déchiré lire
elles paraissent les catastrophes
engendrées par les pétroliers bien
réelle cette époque rouillé par endroits
constellé de mazout nota nyon était un
vieux navire
cela explique peut-être qu'il se soit
brisé en deux dans la tempête
tirée par les 25000 chevaux de l'abeille
languedoc le tanio paraît bien
inoffensifs
pourtant les hommes des remorqueurs se
méfie il est toujours délicat de
tracteurs un navire par l'arrière
dans la cuisine déserté du bateau un
rappel celui du jour où s'est arrêté
l'histoire de ce navire dernier repas
pour huit membres de l'équipage
mais l'addition aurait pu être bien plus
lourd nous sommes venus avec le zodiaque
le long du bord à bâbord par michel
embarcation a pris à la volée et en fait
c'est ciblé l'opération a été rendue
possible grâce à l'habilité du
commandant qui est un excellent
manoeuvrier qui nous est acquis a tenu
l'arrière de la bei
malgré le groupe qui avait aux environs
de 10 mètres de l'arrière ce qu'ils
apprécient beaucoup le travail et le
temps pressés parce que le bateau allait
sur lesquels mais où on était à peu près
à chaque fois en moins d'un moins d'un
mille disons environ 1000 mètres des
cailloux à ce moment là il était temps
de s'attaquer au fond c'était c'est ça
ou rien
le remorquage du tanio s'achève ici
wavre dans ce port pétrolier peu habitué
à recevoir des moitiés de navires il
faudra ensuite transbordés la cargaison
sur des barges la machinerie du
pétrolier qui fonctionne encore sera
utilisée pour mener à bien l'opération
au total si vous voulez compte tenu de
l'état des structures des collecteurs et
divers tuyaux sur le pont et comprenant
aussi le dégazage du navire on compte
une dizaine de jours il n'y a aucun
risque avec ce bateau à quai au havre
absolument
les montois pétroliers comme un autre il
est un petit peu ilan est un peu cassé
mais sans plus 1 et via l'anru mais qui
l'est c'est qu'il est chaque jour un peu
des 10000 tonnes de pétrole qu'il
contient les dix mille tonnes restantes
dans cette partie arrière seront
récupérés car le port pétrolier du havre
possède les installations permettant de
traiter les produits pétroliers même
dénaturé par l'eau de mer
l'idée de sa cargaison ce qui reste du
tanio devrait reprendre la mer il sera
sans doute remorqué jusqu en espagne et
livré aux ferrailleurs sa carcasse est
estimé à un million de fois voyez ce
matin deux jours on apprenait le
naufrage d'un autre pétrolier au large
des côtes espagnoles d'un pétrolier vide
de toute cargaison mais l'explosion a
fait de nombreuses victimes quatre morts
et 32 disparus
hier soir vous parlais de la
séquestration du président en université
de vincennes retenu dans son bureau par
une dizaine d'étudiants
aujourd'hui pierre merlin était libre de
ses faits et gestes la meilleure preuve
sa présence ici si sur notre plateau
plateau il il a même donné ce matin son
cours d'urbanisme cela dit cette
nouvelle étincelle à vincennes a reposé
le cas de cette université par comme les
autres sur laquelle se penchent
maintenant dominique laurie créée en
1968 vincennes reste un cas unique dans
l'univers site
pour les uns c'est le rendez vous des
nostalgiques de mai 68 des marginaux des
faux étudiants pour d'autres au delà du
folklore c'est une université où l'on
travaille plus librement et mieux
qu'ailleurs
depuis 12 ans vincennes a connu des
grandes périodes d'agitation
cette fois les choses sont plus
sérieuses le trafic de drogue a fait son
entrée sur le campus avec ses
conséquences
et si le président a mis en place un
contrôle des cartes d'étudiants il a dû
faire marche arrière sous la pression du
conseil de l'université
mais pour tout le monde la drogue est
présente à vincennes
nous en sommes aperçus à plusieurs
reprises nous avons été émus avec nos
collègues
membre du patient administratif de voir
des jeunes qui étaient
qui venait dans les toilettes des
bâtiments et qui faisait faire de pitié
aussi faisait des piqûres mais à
vincennes un problème succède à un autre
après la drogue des étudiants veulent
imposer au président le retrait de sa
plainte déposée pour falsification de
dossiers contre cette jeune émigré après
une assemblée générale la séquestration
hier de pierre merlin n'a fait que
dégrader une situation déjà très tendue
mais paradoxe de vincennes à l'heure
même où l'agitation se développer autour
du bureau du président dans d'autres
salles on l'étudié et très sérieusement
autre exemple la formation permanente
compte des stages de langues étrangères
de secrétariat et d'animateurs
d'entreprises plus de 15 cents personnes
ont été recyclés en 1979
ça fait huit ans que j'ai arrêté de
travailler et puis j'ai trouvé que
s'enfermer à la maison c'était assez
difficile à supporter donc j'ai envie de
retravailler mais comme je n'avais pas
suffisamment de de base pour me remettre
dans le milieu du travail j'ai préféré
reprendre un stage avant le avant de me
représenter dans une éventuelle
entreprises les raisons qui ont permis
aux grecs moins nombreux finalement mois
via l'armée au cours de philosophie de
françois châtelet c'est la bousculade
ici l'on peut rencontrer un
polytechnicien une employée un
architecte une dactylo ou à l'ingénieux
tandis que leurs enfants sont à la
crèche de l'université
et puis il y aller non bacheliers qui
après une journée de travail viennent le
soir approfondir leurs connaissances
bref tout cela c'est vincennes 40%
d'émigrés 30 % de non bacheliers du
folklore des innovations pédagogiques
une expérience unique en france qui
risquent d'être remises en cause par
l'inconscience ou la marginalité de
quelques-uns
séquestré lâché par une bonne partie du
conseil de l'université
ignoré par l'ensemble des étudiants
pierre merlin est aujourd'hui un homme
seul ou presque et le combat qu'il mène
pour la survie de vincennes devient de
plus en plus difficile camerling quand
on est comme le dit dominique laurie un
homme seul ait ce qu'on n'a pas envie ce
soir de jeter l'épongé
je ne crois pas que soit jeté l'épongé
mais j'ai décidé tout à l'heure de
donner ma démission
les membres de la majorité du conseil de
l'université venait de me remettre la
leur en solidarité avec moi j'ai décidé
de m'y associer donc vous nous est
entrée ce soir que vous abandonnez vos
fonctions à partir de quand à partir de
maintenant je viens d'en prendre la
décision
notre prédécesseur claude free ou a eu
des problèmes vous même pierre merlin
vous êtes là depuis quatre ans à
vincennes votre successeur puisque vous
ne lancez aujourd'hui en aura sans doute
est-ce que le vincennes est un navire
ingouvernable je ne pense pas que
vincent soit définitivement
ingouvernable mais la majorité du
conseil d'université comme moi même
avons jugé intolérable comportement de
quelques-uns avons trouvé inadmissible
que ce soit des membres du conseil de
l'université de la minorité celui ci qui
manipulent en du groupe minoritaire
s'abstient matic mans les institutions
de l'université encore hier avec cette
séquestration qui sont organisés car
elle était organisé par des membres du
conseil de l'université c'est une
accusations assez graves mais pourquoi
est-ce que ils ont intérêt à essayer de
saper cette expérience qu'elle vincennes
et que nous rappeler de mythes laurie il
ya toujours eu un côté suicidaire chez
certains jeux se noie il y à des
pêcheurs en eau trouble
ce n'est qu'une minorité nous espérons
que des missions loin d'être un abandon
sera au contraire l'occasion d'un
sursaut de vincennes de manière à ce que
ce que vous avez vu tout à l'heure soit
préservé parce que vraiment vincennes
doit continuer à exister puisque rien
d'autre ne peut apporter à ses salariés
ce que vincennes apporter doit continuer
à porter vous pouvez pas préciser vos
d'accusation est ce que c'est une
minorité politique qui cherche à vous
bloquez en dessous ces socialistes
votent pas laisser seul a été communiste
c'est un problème politique
c'est en partie en problèmes politiques
effectivement beaucoup de ces personnes
se réclament d'une de très vagues
d'ailleurs
au logis gauchiste mais ce sont avant
tout les gens qui s'apprend vincennes
sapant les institutions universitaires
font le jeu du ministère du tutelle qui
nous a pas ménagé comme chacun sait le
départ de vincennes pour ça ni l'année
prochaine sans coûts donc que ne va pas
arranger les choses
je n'avais jamais accepté le principe de
ceux des peurs je ne sais pas ce qui va
se passer mais il est certain que les
événements des derniers jours l'ont fait
considérablement avancer et vous avez
l'impression conscience que dans
l'opinion vincennes n'est pas très
populaire même si à l'étranger
effectivement la scène a une bonne
réputation
vous savez vincent était pas très
populaire dans l'opinion vincennes a par
contre une réputation unique à
l'étranger mais la réalité profonde de
20,7 si vous avez vu tout à l'heure ce
sont ces stages de formation permanente
sont salariés qui viennent après leur
travail et c'est ça que nous avons le
devoir de préserver
j'espère que ceux qui le succéderont le
front merci pierre merlin d'être venu
nous annoncer avec émotion donc votre
démission à l'instant même de la
présidence de l'université de vincennes
sncf perturbations importantes ce matin
sur la banlieue nord de paris quelques
cheminots avait devancé le mot d'ordre
de grève de la cgt applicable en
principe depuis un quart d'heure et
jusqu'à samedi matin par de très grosses
perturbations à prévoir dit toutefois la
sncf
pas de perturbation non plus chez nous
dit air france je vous rappelle qu' hier
le tribunal des référés déclaré dean
licite la grève du syndicat des
mécaniciens navigant qui décident de
reporter son mouvement et puisque nous
parlions tout à l'heure de la sncf
sachez qu'à partir de lundi tous les
tarifs voyageurs seront majorés de 9,4
pour cent sauf pour les lignes de
banlieue et bien précisément le point
sur d'autres os celle du crédit toutes
les banques se sont pratiquement aligner
aujourd'hui le point philippe sassier
les banques et les établissements
spécialisés sont en train de relever le
tarif de leurs crédits y à partir du 1er
avril ces crédits seront également plus
rares en moins d'un an le taux de base
bancaire est passé de moins de 9% à plus
de 13%
ce taux de base qui est théorique sert
uniquement de référence au calcul du
prix les emprunts que vous pouvez faire
pour acheter une automobile ou bien un
logement si vous voulez emprunter pour
une longue durée pour vous loger par
exemple quel tout vous sont proposés
pour une durée de 15 ans les caisses
d'epargne propose
jour peut être pas pour très longtemps
un taux de l'ordre de 13%
elles sont suivies de près par le crédit
mutuel avec trey et demi pour cent une
grande banque nationalisée offre un taux
de près de 16 et demi pour cent tandis
que celui d'un organisme spécialisé
varie entre un peu plus de 16% et un peu
plus de 17% ce rapide coup d'oeil sur la
ligne bleue des taux du crédit appelle
une première question comment s'y
retrouver et comment choisir son prêteur
la réponse il faut comparer les sommes
que vous allez payer chaque mois pour
rembourser votre crédit dans une caisse
d'epargne un emprunt sur 15 ans de dix
mille francs c'est à dire 1 millions de
centimes vous coûtera chaque mois - 222
francs
le même emprunts auprès du crédit mutuel
ou faudra débourser un peu plus de 130
de francs avec la grande banque
nationalisée
cette charge mensuelle passe à 150
francs et à l'établissement spécialisé
toujours pour dix mille francs emprunter
sur 15 ans prélèvera une somme identique
multiplier ces montants mensuels par le
nombre des millions de centimes emprunté
et vous obtenez votre charge de
remboursement
deuxième question les prix du crédit bat
actuellement des records
alors faut-il quand même empreinte quand
on pose cette question la réponse
commence par un homme femme dubitatif et
significatif les uns affirment il faut
plutôt attendre pour s'endetter cette
escalade des taux ne peut pas continuer
éternellement mais les autres assurent
en attendant que le crédit baisse ce
sont les prix du logement qui augmente
c'est l'action sont toutes les deux
valables
une chose est certaine avant d'emprunter
il faut y regarder à deux fois
et puis il ya un espoir pour les
épargnants il se pourrait que dans les
jours qui viennent les taux d'intérêt
dans les caisses d'epargne soit relevé
willow renchérissement du crédit n'est
pas sans inquiéter les professionnels du
bâtiment qui ont peur que les français
achètent moins et là n'est pas leur seul
problème puisqu'ils se sont émus d'une
lettre que raymond barre a dressé il ya
quatre jours aux administrations pour
leur demander de réduire leurs dépenses
et une des premières conséquences qui
pourraient être la réduction des
dépenses d'investissement dans le budget
80 donc une diminution de la
construction les crédits budgétaires
80plus le coup de pouce du plan de
soutien en septembre dernier
doivent permettre de construire quatre
cent trente mille logements cette année
à peu près comme l'an passé
voilà les professionnels rassurer pour
le premier semestre de cette année mais
les mesures de ces derniers mois
notamment fiscales
les inquiète pour la suite c'est le pré
patronales dont seront écartés de
nombreux cadres la tva sur les terrains
qui augmente de 7% l'assurance
construction + 2 à 3% et surtout le
crédit le crédit plus cher ses quelque
5000 acquéreur de moins en ile-de-france
le crédit plus rare
trente mille logements de moins par
exemple pour le seul crédit agricole et
maintenant avec le budget 80 voici la
diminution des autorisations de
programme c'est à dire le déblocage des
crédits
une diminution qui à moyen terme menace
l'emploi faut pas l'oublier chez nous
quand il ya un emploi grâce à nos
fournisseurs grâce à ce qui est derrière
nous il y a deux emplois au total
et tant et si bien que si vraiment on
mineurs de 20% aux crédits budgétaires
ça fera avec l'inflation ressemblant 30%
de logements en moins et auquel cas pour
l'emploi c'est peut-être 5000 personnes
qui partiront notre profession c'est
considérable je crois qu'il vaut mieux
le savoir avant qu'après ça sera quand
je pense au printemps ou à l'été 80
accueilli à l'étranger maintenant à
commencer par la suite de l'échec de la
commission d' enquête de l'onu qui n'a
pas rencontré ou le savez les otages
américains de teyran aujourd'hui ma une
belle jaoui le président de cette
commission a rendu compte de la mission
à courte valdes à m le secrétaire
général de l'onu pour les familles des
otages qui recommençaient à reprendre
espoir
ces deux nouveaux l'angoissent comment
aujourd'hui réajuste vous avez beaucoup
de tristesse vraiment parce que
j'espérais commission
pouvait faire ces choses dans une
semaine dans deux semaines vous êtes en
contact régulièrement avec les familles
des otages
aujourd'hui que vous en tête ils sont
calmées famille le problème reste
maintenant avec au menu je pense et
c'est pour ça que je ne peux plus 1 voir
que la commission va rester sans s'en
fait rien clear
je suis sûr que le comédien claude
mission par roue tourne et après les
élections et le président carter peut-il
faire aujourd'hui
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce qu'il
fait pour le moment oui oui il a
trafiqué l'insensé hausse très patient
lors aux tenues
oui c'est le meilleur mais aujourd'hui
ça ne suffit peut être pas pour le
moment oui je suis sûr qu'on doit on
doit rester comme ça avec un c'est votre
physique
c'est donc dans le cadre vous pensez
madame que aujourd'hui le président
carter ne pourrait pas faire autre chose
qu'il ne montre peut-être pas qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire chaque chose militaire
n'ont pour l'heure ce n'a pas posé de
problèmes électoraux à jimmy carter qui
s'est débarrassé facilement d'edward
kennedy dans les primaires de géorgie
d'alabama et de floride
du côté républicain en ahl reagan a lui
aussi battu facilement george bush
yougoslavie l'état de santé du marshall
tito ce soir les médecins qui le
soignent n'espère plus que quelques
jours de survie tous les organes vitaux
du malade sont irrémédiablement altérée
et le maréchal est maintenant victime
d'une grave hémorragie interne
in opéras pendant ce temps à panama le
shah d'iran
on doit être opéré de l'ablation de la
rate cette intervention est devenu
indispensable à la suite du cancer du
système lymphatique dont souffre depuis
de nombreux mois
l'ex empereur iranien qui vous voyez
marx est prêt valéry giscard d'estaing
dimanche soir hambourg l'invitation du
chancelier helmut schmidt les deux
dirigeants européens qui rentrent
respectivement du proche orient et des
états unis
examinons la situation internationale
mouche mythe a déjà fait savoir sa
totale identité de vue avec valéry
giscard d'estaing sur
l'autodétermination du peuple
palestinien
le roi hassan ii a lui aussi apporté son
soutien au président français sur ce
point précis il a dit tout à l'heure sur
france inter dans face au public
sport en cyclisme paris nice et finit à
l'issue des deux dernières demi étape
gilbert duclos-lassalle l'emportent au
classement général et celle hollandais
knetemann qui a gagné la course contre
la montre du col d'eze dominique
duvauchelle 11 km 20 minutes 28 le pôle
hollandais avec net mann spécialiste du
contre-la-montre s'est imposé au col
d'eze devant le français michel laurent
et le suédois prime
gilbert duclos lassalle n'a terminé qu'à
la 6e place mais a conservé trois
minutes d'avancé au classement général
sur le suisse müstair duclos lassalle
pour du jeu dati se présentent au micro
de jean paul ollivier donc j'ai pas mal
de défauts parce que je suis pas un
grand coureur comme je dis je grimpe à
l'école et color à eau de pourcentage
je roule à très bien je vais à peu près
assez vite alors disons que je suis moi
y importe où je suis pas un gros
spécialistes de qualité
vous êtes originaire des basses pyrénées
est originaire d'un petit pays qui
s'appelle lembeye
c'est exact jarny originaire de lembeye
qui se trouve à 30 km de pau et c'est là
où je fête mes préparations hivernants
les cas je rentre chez moi
vous avez des frères et les soeurs ses
trois frères et une soeur
on est content on va faire la fête à
lembeye ce soir mais je pense que quand
je vais rentrer tout le monde veut me
cueillir les bras ouverts parce que je
représente quand même le cyclisme bon
niveau dans cette région surtout que
c'est une région du rugby est pas
produit et l'eau
il y aura un tiercé de vincennes dans le
prix de dormans voici les pronostics de
pierrette brès vous allez le voir
s'inscrire sur cet écran le 6 19
le 3 le 14 las le 15
le 12 et le 16
les résultats du loto maintenant pour
gagner il fallait jouer le 3 le 9 le 10
sept
le 38 46 48 et comme numéro
complémentaire le 47 aujourd'hui la
météo les températures étaient douces
mais il a plu sur le nord du pays
généralement le ciel a été couvert
demain
eh bien demain nous allons le découvrir
sur la carte il fera beaucoup plus frais
sur tout le nord du pays avec même
parfois quelques giboulées il neigera en
montagne mais le soleil se montrera sur
la médicale